will you ever believe your eyes when
deep fakes spread their lies defects
appear to be improving you know they're
the video and audio clips made using AI
tools to mimic the voice and or the
likeness of pretty much anyone you want
for example you could sway an election
with a deep fake of Biden making sense
this week a deep fake of Liz Warren
depicted her saying Republicans
shouldn't be allowed to vote
nice try though the real Liz Warren
would have had feathers and Beads
go for it here are some other famous
examples
I am not Morgan Freeman and what you see
is not real her enemies can make it look
like anyone is saying anything at any
point in time imagine this for a second
one man with total control of billions
of people stolen data listen up Sports
and Tick Tock fans
if you like what you're seeing just wait
till it's coming next
please
that didn't look at all like Costner so
now now it's going to be even harder to
trust the news or anything really
because what looks real could now be
completely fake I mean you could be
tricked into believing that I'm short
but maybe this is good now you're always
skeptical and now you're always
distressful and that's not a bad
perspective to have base it the media is
already less trusted than Andrew Cuomo
at a nursing home they've been forcing
deep fakes on us for decades the P tape
with Trump Hunter's laptop isn't real
russiagate the popularity of Maroon 5
the food pyramid Biden running for
president Ellen DeGeneres being friendly
transitory inflation Steve ducey's thigh
curl record
all lies so maybe we shouldn't believe
our eyes and ears anymore or at all for
example here are some deep fakes that I
can't tell are real or fake
hello I'm Brian Kilmeade everything Greg
says about me is true I'm awkward smelly
and my books are terrible I carry a
backpack because I like to pretend I'm a
High School freshman all of my friends
only pretend to like me because they
feel sorry for me my only wish is that I
could be more like Greg Gutfeld wow that
sounded pretty accurate to me do we have
another
Jesse Waters here my outward appearance
of confidence is a fraud deep down I'm
scared I'm not half the man Greg is
personally or professionally
that's why I hide behind hair
transplants cologne and pants that are
too tight money helps though that's why
I'm plotting a Ponzi scheme
ah wow one more do we have one more
hey it's Dana the truth is I hate dogs
I've always been more of a cat person
also I once robbed a casino when I was
16 and I'd do it again in a heartbeat
you know your girl's got to get that
money dollar bills y'all dollar bills
y'all
Chris do you think this is going to go
beyond just pure entertainment value
deep fix yeah oh my a thousand first of
all there's not a guy out there right
now that should ever get caught cheating
on his wife again he'll be like baby it
was a deep phase it's a deep fake so I
would uh I think that this is gonna get
bad and I want to say congratulations to
Dave Rubin he just had a third kid in
the commercial break so here you go
that isn't science it's Satanism you
know I was thinking with this deep fake
thing what if you sitting in front of me
right now what if you yourself are a
deep fake for example what if you were
actually Jimmy Kimmel wanting to be on
the number one show in late night
television
I like the spiteful Dave Rubin better I
like yeah gosh all right last time I
like Miami Dave
[Laughter]
Papyrus are you worried
uh what you're seeing is the
watered-down version of this this has
been around for a while uh and it's the
the level of cameras have gotten to the
point where all you really need is just
a segment of somebody and you can chop
and cut and change everything they're
saying so we're not seeing it yet but
you'll start seeing videos about once it
becomes political or someone's able to
use it to be foolproof you'll one
thousand percent see it the good news is
is that people will will stop putting so
much faith into videos clips of videos
seeing the last three seconds of
something and all of a sudden that
explains the whole story so people
actually have to start looking at things
because the longer the video the harder
it is to manipulate yeah so now you'll
start having when people actually have
to watch something they'll have to see
in its entirety and then you'd be amazed
what you actually might see when you
with a lot of the things that were
programmed to react to with videos cat
everybody's gonna end up like you
they're gonna can't where they won't
trust anything you'll have to verify it
before you buy it that's not bad
no
[Applause]
so there already are deep fakes of me on
the internet yes I'm not talking
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh that was really fun to explain to my
70 year old Aunt yeah that uh no that
girl has
[Laughter]
um
that wasn't me doing that
so that's disturbing it's like deeply
disturbing when it comes to the ones and
look as everybody's gonna stop watching
and go Google you sick
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um
we have that problem with real videos
though already yeah like people will
just take a segment of something you
said and this has happened to me
countless times as to you and other
people and then someone will tweet it
say you were talking about something
completely different right and nobody
bothers to check so we're already at a
place where people need to verify things
so and they don't so will they verify
this I don't really know have you ever
been tricked by anything I could say
that I I mean I go back to like even the
I would say even like the Covington kids
thing even was not a deep fake but the
way it was edited that's what Kat was
saying was is he fake I'm trying to
think of any of these any of these last
fakeries got me no I don't know that
anything really got me I love it when
people send me one and I get to tell
them it's fake makes me feel so smart oh
yeah I saw that it's fake and then they
go really I do that to Jesse a lot
because he falls for it so much stuff
yeah I mean he needs they need to like
check his computer to see what he looks
at it's really gross all right I think
we should go to commercial hey Sean
Hannity here here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else